مره جديده يحقق لهم ماستر رقم قياسيا هذه
المره بخسارته اكبر ثروه سجلت في التاريخ
200 مليار دولار نعم الرقم صحيح ولكن
الوضع ليس شيئا الى هذه الدرجه فلا تزال
قيمه الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تسلا سبيس اكس
اكس تويتر
137 مليار دولار وهو جيد بما يكفي لا يحتل
المركز الثاني في قائمه اغنى اغنياء
العالم
[موسيقى]
كان نمو ثروه الى ماسك مدفوعه بالاساس من
حصته في تسلا بعد ان تجاوزت القيمه
السوقيه للشركه تريليون دولار لاول مره في
اكتوبر عام 2021 لتنضم الى الشركات
التكنولوجيا العملاقه ابل و مايكروسوفت
وامازون
والقناص باللون
الاكبر في الانزلاق الذي قضى على حوالي
675 مليار دولار من القيمه السوقيه للشركه
هذا العام بل اضافه الى تغريدته المستمره
على تويتر وسلوكه غير المنتظم بشكل متزايد
بكل الاحوال قد يرتاد سهم تسلى ويمكن ان
يصبح ماسك مره اخرى اغنى شخص في العالم
ولكن سمعته باعتباره عبقريا تعرضت لبعض
الاضرار الجسيمه عام 2022 تقريبا بقدر
الضرر الذي تعرضت له ثروته الشخصيه لصباح
العربيات واشنطن
[موسيقى]